bonjour Anthony Saint-Léger bonjour à
tous alors que l'extrême droite est
arrivé en tête des législatives en
Italie des internautes sur vidéo à
l'appui que des patriotes italiens ont
envoyé un avertissement à l'Union
européenne en enlevant le drapeau
européen d'un bâtiment à Rome
expliquez-nous ça et bien c'est dans une
vidéo d'une quarantaine de secondes que
l'on peut découvrir ça on va la
découvrir ensemble évidemment cette
vidéo il s'agirait donc de patriotes
italien dans un dans un sur un bâtiment
de Rome qui décrocherait vous le voyez
un drapeau européen dans le but de le
remplacer par le drapeau italien cette
vidéo on l'a retrouvée à de nombreuses
reprises sur Twitter Facebook ou encore
d'autres réseaux sociaux et extrêmement
partagés vous voyez ce tweet par exemple
cette vue via ce tweet 700 plus de 700
000 vues différents internautes de ce
féliciter finalement de ce geste ou même
pour certains c'est le cas par exemple
de celui-ci d'évoquer une réponse au
menaces formulées par
Ursula fenderlione la présidente de la
Commission européenne une référence
faite aux propos que la présidente a
fait la semaine dernière a pris une
stand dans dans laquelle des propos dans
lesquels elle évoquait justement des
outils comprenez peut-être des sanctions
en cas de victoire de l'extrême droite
au législative italienne donc sauf que
cette vidéo que vous nous avez montré
elle date qu'il y a 9 ans effectivement
rien à voir avec l'actualité récente et
la vérification est assez simple on
utilise des outils de recherche d'images
inversée en l'occurrence celui-ci indeed
oui verify c'est assez simple
d'utilisation il vous suffit dans cet
outil de renseigner l'une des adresses
Twitter sur lequel avec laquelle vous
avez pu voir cette vidéo vous voyez que
ça fragmente en différentes captures
d'écran et ça va surtout vous permettre
de connaître l'origine en l'occurrence
l'origine de la vidéo la voici elle a
été publiée par un média italien en
décembre 2013 donc il y a neuf ans on va
retrouver la séquence virale on est à 2
minutes 30 de cette vidéo on va passer
l'image un petit peu graphique voilà
l'image virale donc elle provient bien
de cette vidéo on est en décembre 2013
je vous le disais c'est un rassemblement
d'un groupe néo-fasciste Casa Pound ce
bâtiment c'est le siège de la Commission
européenne à Rome et il s'agit d'une
manifestation contre les politiques
économiques menées par Bruxelles à
l'époque et pour la souveraineté
nationale l'homme que l'on voit qui
décroche donc ce drapeau c'est lui
Simonnet dit Stefano il est alors
vice-président du Casa Pound et ce geste
lui aura valu d'ailleurs trois mois de
prison et 100 euros d'amende Georgina
Georgia pardon Meloni à la tête du parti
et d'extrême droite certains internautes
ont voulu semble-t-il de la discréditer
effectivement et notamment en ce qui
concerne son meeting de Palerme la
semaine dernière voici le type de photo
que l'on a pu voir sur les réseaux
sociaux assez partagés des photos qui
montrent une foule assez importante vous
en conviendrez et certains de noter tout
de même des répétitions vous le voyez
dans dans les foules en question des
événements qui se répètent on pourrait
jouer ici ah oui Charlie hein regardez
vous retrouvez ces personnes ici ici
encore ou encore voilà il y a plusieurs
exemples je vous montrerai pas tout
évidemment des photomontages assez
grossiers vous en conviendrez
certainement utiliser pour la
discréditer l'accusant donc de vouloir
grossir les rangs visuellement via ces
photos de campagne sauf que ces photos
en question ne proviennent absolument
pas du clan mélonie voici les originales
si on cherche un petit peu sur ces
réseaux sociaux vous avez ici le compte
Twitter de Georgia Meloni le compte
artificielle et vous retrouvez les deux
photos en question et lorsque l'on
regarde de plus près vous voyez bien que
la foule annoncée n'était pas du tout
sur les photos originales toutefois il y
a un détail qui a attiré l'oeil des
internautes aussi qui a taraudé même les
internautes regardez c'est ici c'est la
taille des chaussures de Georgia Meloni
ça je rappelle que c'est bien la photo
officielle et pour certains c'est une
preuve donc de manipulation d'avoir une
chaussure un petit peu dirons-nous plus
longue que ce qu'on pourrait attendre et
comme l'ont noter nos confrères de
italiens de check regardez c'est
vraisemblablement l'utilisation d'un
objectif grand angle ou en tout cas d'un
filtre pour la personne qui a réalisé le
cliché qui donne cette impression parce
que vous voyez bien ici quand en
appliquant un correctif de cet objectif
et bien Georgia Meloni paraît plus fine
ou en tout cas dans une autre proportion
et ses chaussures également que la photo
qu'elle même a publié sur son compte
Twitter merci beaucoup Anthony
Saint-Léger pour cette explication
d'image vous restez avec nous on se
retrouve dans quelques instants pour un
nouveau journal dans ce Paris direct